how are you doing today sir
so far pretty good so like we can change
all that though if this interview goes
sideways okay just saying so my first
question for you is uh what do you think
fans are going to think when the after
they watch the finale
how would I know what fans are going to
think I have no clue that's like me what
are you thinking right now I have no
clue I can tell you this I think fans
are going to want more
I know being a part of the cast
having directed a couple now I want more
because I think the show is so well
orchestrated I think the The Producers
the writers favreaux and filoni do such
a great job
it's like man I think people just want
more I like learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of a show so
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about the making of the
Mandalorian both as an actor and as a
director
what would surprise them to learn uh
maybe that I'm never there
that actually
I just get on the phone
and record myself
and then I send it to them and then they
actually put it in the movies
yeah that response is a perfect response
because that makes no sense how would I
know what's surprising for people to
learn I mean like you know what are some
of the interesting things because you've
worked on a number of projects yeah but
it's all the same thing man when it's
all worked even with the technology
involved in them technology it's like
what would be surprising for people to
learn about the internet before the
internet is there there's nothing
surprising to learn it's technologically
done and it's done beautifully by all of
these artists I will oh I'll switch to
something else so you obviously direct
you have directed episodes yes uh I've
heard that the Mandalorian season four
hypothetically could be filming this
year have you uh news to me have you
approached have you asked John and Dave
about directing one
no do they ask like how does that work
do they ask you do you sort of like well
I mean John could say do you want to
direct another or more I'd say yes
please
um but no I you know it's all a process
and part of the first part of it is he's
got a Brandon with you know Disney plus
see if they want to do more and then
when that decision is made then it's
about what the stories are going to be
and who's going to be in them and then
it's about production and who's going to
direct and blah blah blah blah blah so
for me it's just I'm so enjoying being a
part of this now when and if the time
comes that they ask if I want to be a
part of it again
yes please let's go sir we are all fans
of yours at Collider